[Musik]
kann diese scheiße musik mal aufhören
hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video hier sehen wir schon im titel
eingeblendet dieses quiz ist unmöglich
ich habe nämlich bei google dass
eingegeben und da kam diese webseite
hier raus ihr seht schon da steht
einfach nur beginnen aber da klicken wir
es noch mal drauf kammermusik mal wieder
wie impossible quickstart instructions
credits let me to set the dividend alt
ich würde sagen wir kriegen jetzt mal
auf instruction um zu sehen wo ich kann
[Musik]
ich mache die musik mal australopithecus
bei entering the question is it also wir
sollen quasi das quiz schaffen wir
nehmen wir alle fragen beantworten aber
es ist das impossible kurs also das
unmögliche kurs also complete die
downsizing jetzt fahrt bei den smart
impossible okay das impossible christus
also nicht impossible er sagt uns jetzt
gerade auch noch das nicht hier
dreileben am start habe und wenn ich
drei leben verliere bin ich halt dann
ist halt vorbei aber ich würde sagen wir
fangen mal ein handy holz in paolo also
im polo sind 123 aber ich weiß nicht ob
er mich vielleicht fragt zu haben in
diekholzen paulo weil da ist ja auch
noch ein loch und da das ganze so ein
[ __ ] puls ist drücke ich einfach
mal noch 4
das heißt richtig oder sonst hätte ich
ja zwei leben oder henning matchbox ich
verstehe die frage nicht was labert also
yes oder no wäre auf jeden fall zu easy
als antwort das heißt entweder norbert
in kellern oder es gibt eis nicht
klicken
[Musik]
was denn sonst nobody team kein okay
okay das war richtig es ist trocken
[Musik]
ach das ist rückwärts elvis question
beck war okay
dennis abbott jubi ernst guten die maus
und hier
okay wer will jetzt dass ich meine maus
nach unten auf das gute ding packe aber
ich muss auch meine maus einfach auch
hier packen oder weil sonst wäre das
doch nicht so versteht ihr was ich meine
wurde die maus und hier okay ich werde
das jetzt machen aber das wird das ich
werten leben abgezogen bekommen
don't touch too
was
[Musik]
jürgen schaff das größe einfach die
quadratwurzel aus bosnien 28 auf keinen
fall also die quadratwurzel aus
beispielsweise 9 ist ja drei weil
dreimal sich selber multipliziert also
drei mal drei ist neu und ich weiß nicht
28 28 ist doch nicht an ihren mann und
ihren und ein ion was daraus verstehen
ich drück einfach mal achten ich dachte
es wäre so einfach gewesen statt
vielleicht okay okay das war richtig
weil scheine das hat glaube ich auch
irgendwas zu tun mit zwiebeln die ernte
dann beliebig
es könnte alles sein warum er sagt mir
die ente ist riesig und ich mache das
ganze jetzt einfach mal von vorne also
vor kenne matchbox nobakht in kansas ist
christian beckers ok klickt die emmaus
und hier jetzt außenrum zurück und dann
auf next question die quadratwurzel aus
einer zwiebel sind charlie beck ja war
davor hinwil die big richtig ich glaube
auch falsch kann diese scheiße musik mal
aufhören robert enke ok und kriegen sie
hier die maus sind einmal außen rum next
question and elephant search
no they do not want to know what the
answer questions
drei wochen später
ich verstehe allgemein nicht wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel hier draufklicken ist
dann ja dieses hier richtig oder und
dann das tier dann das hier dann das von
warum ihr können bin ich sagen dass das
möglich ist zum siebten mal remis holte
prolog vor kenne matchbox nobody team
kennen das da ist doch richtig die
dingsda unten links das ist die richtige
antwort noch bei der tim kaine
ok-präsident hier die maus sind einmal
außen rum next question stelle
okay diese antwort hier war richtig das
heißt ich muss hier draufklicken ok
chubut
wo ist hier food das hier ist ein
handschuh das hier ist ein auge das hier
ist ein stuhl das ist ein stift und dass
das war käse wahrscheinlich oder ich
sehe gerade ich habe hier ein skript
dazu bekommen das heißt ich kann
wahrscheinlich eine frage gleich kippen
weil ich als drei leben haben und
irgendwie schon zehn fragen richtig
beantwortet habe er weiß allerdings
nicht dass ich das christie gerade schon
zum vierzigsten mal spiele portfolios
dezember second dezember fällt oder
question portfolios dezembersession
fragezeichen also kunst
[Musik]
diese website ist eine verdammte
missgeburt locker ist einfach die
silberförderung and click the smallest
ok meine damen und herren das hier ist
zwar das kleinste aber es is back to
black block blockade würde
[Musik]
da kann man doch nur raten was wäre da
richtig gewesen meine damen und herren
was hättet ihr angeklickt das hier warum
ich
instructions durchgelesen und genau das
ist wirklich eingetreten so viele
fucking fragen haben einfach nur etwas
mit raten zu tun
what can i am the box to make it leiter
also was können wir in einen topf oder
einen eimer tun um ihn leichter zu
machen holt endlager gibt
warum doch es ist nur noch sinnvoll
[Musik]
was hat langweilig alter jetzt verstehe
ich das auch man soll den dänen den
eimern nicht leichter machen sondern
leiter heißt ja auch dass der
erleuchteter wird deswegen auch eine
fackel wenn paar sekunden später ich
habe gerade gegoogelt was bei frage 15
rauskommen und man musste horst hin
schreiben also hrsg ich weiß nicht warum
oder wieso oder wie man da auch in
gottes namen drauf kommen soll aber es
war ja jetzt richtig gut ist wie stevens
hatte auch die erste bei dm wieder die
meinen das wort 11 wird das ist nämlich
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 also ein ehe das heißt wir
haben keine ich kann mir trotzdem ich
verstehe dass sie das richtige alphabet
neuen b c d e f g
okay ein gs wird natürlich nicht dass
die
was denn sonst was
drücke ob b c d e f g h es ist der achte
fach um 24.7 es eigentlich 17
warum ist sie nirgends wurde 17
angegeben leicht barros 16 einmal ich
versuche es noch einmal viel know but i
think and ok klickt ihr ins haus ab hier
außenrum next war ich schon mal kurz
einfach vor bis zu der frage
24/7 ich weiß dass es auf keinen fall
walross ist und das untere das heißt es
wird wahrscheinlich 25 als 18
das ist nicht
das ist nicht wahr wie so komme ich da
nicht drauf ich hatte es mir gedacht ich
habe mir gedacht okay das ist die
siebzehnte frage aber das ist nicht wahr
das ist nicht wahr ich muss das hier
drücken ist das ist das deren ernst
stopp okay was was passt für stop ok wo
muss ich drauf drücken was ist was ist
jetzt schon wieder irgendwie irgendwann
wie was wo irgendwo hier oben vielleicht
irgendwie was komme ich finde ich werde
jetzt mal den skippern ok power in the
correct order
wie wie soll ich auch nur ansatzweise
auf die lösung kommen
es kann ja sein dass ich alles in blau
machen muss
ich hab jetzt gedacht hat es in blau
machen wegen der blauen aufschrift hier
oben wartet
ich hasse mein leben